all right here we are now Lawrence this
is for you if you do not win the
Democratic nomination come on what are
the chances of that will you run as a
third party candidate look I want to be
a Democratic candidate I want to have a
chance on the Democratic stage to rally
people to what I think is an issue at
the core of the Democratic Party
restoring democracy to the people and
that's what I want to do I want the
chance to do that now it's been hard
because you know I may teach her ID I'm
not a billionaire I'm not a politician
if I were a politician I could be paid
while I was running for the United
States presidency but as a teacher once
I start running I got to give up my job
so there's a period of time where I can
run on credit cards and savings accounts
when they can't pay me from the campaign
or anything where I try to get into the
race and what I did in my case was raise
a million dollars in less than 30 days
that's more than five Republican
candidates it's more than Jim Webb and
lincoln Chafee and it's just about
exactly what O'Malley raised I rallied
10,000 people to the campaign we have a
real campaign staff I qualified for
public funding but the Democratic Party
wouldn't even acknowledge me as a
candidate and so the polls wouldn't
include me on their polls and so when
they said 1% you have to be out to be in
this race I would be careful about this
is kind of what Jim Webb was doing the
other night office whiny and then people
know we're into the debate I twit well
let me talk I tweeted that you should be
included so I was trying to help you out
but the point but the question is build
a here's the question we know that was
really but you're on the other side to
do to be able to rely everybody in the
Republican debate but you know I think
we've been this mulberry bush but the
issue I think is being raised by by the
other candidate I but if the issue is
how do we get a democracy rose like how
do we make that the priority what
borough said another debate I mean one
line that I think was the most important
line not mentioned by anybody he said if
we're gonna have any chance of
addressing these problems we've got to
deal with ket with campaign finance
which is exactly but this is 80% of
Republicans agree with you according to
the blue
by polling this week which is fast about
his life is about the damn email I mean
one of my big problems with liberals in
this era is the their ability to nitpick
fights on the very very very very very
far end of the spectrum you know Dolce
and Gabanna remember that how dare they
say because they're too ancient Italian
men that they don't think that the baby
should be made artificially well you
know you agree with them on 99% of the
thing they're two gay men you really
want to pick this I don't know about
this example you're saying Bill but I do
believe well I'll tell you I follow
Dolce Gabanna but in stores not this but
but but I believe very much in working
with people and you subsume a lot of the
differences you might have to make to
campaign on one big issue and I don't
believe in sectarian fights and I think
the liberal is the real problem with
liberals over the last decades has been
that they haven't taken their own side
in the fight and I think one of the
things that's appealing to a Bernie
Sanders put aside socialism is he's a
fighter and he's fighting half the
people that he's fighting instead of
fighting him the good thing about change
upon a thing is established
unequivocally that Elton John is king of
the gays right okay nation was founded
150 years ago to redeem the promise of
democracy I do not make it a small issue
Johan what's behind the rise of
anti-establishment candidates like
Jeremy Corbyn in the UK yeah the Jeremy
Corbyn is the candidate for the Liberal
Party and he is way out there to the
left I mean it's like more than Bernie
Sanders even is here I mean way to
lifted yeah name of his positions that
would that would establish this point
well it's very interesting one of the
key things about Jeremy Corbyn is that
he's a rejection of the New Labour
project so I think one of these happen
in the u.s. is the the Bush years were
so horrific and so awful that it kind of
precluded some of the things that went
wrong under the New Democrats and under
Clinton and Jeremy Corbyn that in really
we didn't have that same gap in Britain
so Jeremy Corbyn is really about first
thing he said was about apologizing for
the Iraq
but also about rejecting so much of the
kind of neoliberalism of the new labor
years of the Tony Blair years and I
think a similar thing has to Bernie
actually represents a similar critique
the Clinton years although he doesn't
couch it as that and we really need that
a lot of the things that are going wrong
for those people in Vegas that I met
they did go wrong under the Clinton
years we can forget that you're right
that there were good things as well it's
important to acknowledge oh no I'm not a
glutton booth yeah I know I know yeah
all right John do you see Marco Rubio as
a serious content what yes yes I mean
he's the guy I predict now win the
nomination I think it's going to come
down to three three folks it's going to
come down to on the establishment side
Rubio Kasich or Jeb I still think Jeb
has a shot and I think on the other side
it's gonna be Ted Cruz I don't like Ted
Cruz I don't want him to be it but I
think it's gonna be him so it's gonna be
one of those against one of those three
against Ted Cruz final-final mom well
it's what you put on Trump being the
nominee 20% oh yeah the media has
completely turned around let me let me
say something about Donald Trump and
this no one has played the media better
than Donald Trump yes he is but but no
one has done social media with the
Twitter's he is dominating the news
coverage of this whole this whole
campaign in ways that no one has ever
seen because he does it off the cuff and
he's authentic in his own kind of crazy
way I think it's I think it's better to
talk about social media but this past
summer I don't want him this past summer
was an example of media malpractice at
its highest oh good they did not turn on
a TV set without Donald Trump all the
others listen listen you preaching to
the establish acquire but I will say and
I mean let me say this let me say this
that the reason he got in the news so
much is because he's newsworthy and he
says stuff that and it was really great
and in the world we listen take 8 weeks
to line the depths of Donald Trump's
brain like we could figure that out in
about a week he's always but if you look
at you man he's a quick baby but he's
gonna click but we had a huge amount of
coverage about this ridiculous emails
and then less less coverage of Bernie
Sanders family
sweet eh tink why you guys run the media
remembering Hillary Clinton was at
Donald Trump's wedding she took money
from him right when we talked about this
issue when we took $8,000 yep do we
think that Hillary Clinton was at Don
Trump's wedding because she likes him
and wants to hang out the panel expect
any revelations to come out of Hillary
Clinton's testimony before the Benghazi
committee right we'll be off next week I
think she testifies on a Thursday we
should have mentioned here on the air
tonight a second Republican this week
came out and basically said the thing is
rigged it was it was just to take
political potshots at her they can't
even keep that quiet so it's right it's
a lot it's a longer running committee
than the Watergate committee it's wasted
about 4.6 million dollars however I'm
sure John that Watergate committee
wasn't she she was I have a contrary
vote that wasn't [ __ ] was a senator
there was a senator named Senator
William Fulbright who I think in 1966
held hearings on the Vietnam War I think
this country would be served well by a
real Benghazi committee which would look
at where the United States policy been
one of regime change what were we doing
in Libya what is that led to in the
crisis we see play out in the Middle
East that is a real kinetic you know I
think
I think it freaked out he has been
trying to do the right things I do think
that the Republicans have tripped all
over themselves and if if they were
trying to do the right things the media
attention now is then whatever effort
they put into it
they've been kind of cite the tragedy of
all this [ __ ] opposition is that it
prevents the real opposition that the
Democrats actually do need because they
do lots of bad things well you know I'm
rooting for you John all right thank you
everybody I appreciate your help
you